>> THERE’S NO SUBSTITUTE FOR
BEING HERE.
THIS WAS AN UNFORCED ERROR ON
THE PART OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
I’M HOPING THAT THERE’S ENOUGH
POLITICAL WILL ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE TO DO WHAT
THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND THAT’S NOT TO
TRY TO FIX SOMETHING THAT
WASN’T BROKEN AND GO BACK TO
WHAT IS WORKING.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT.
RIGHT NOW NOTHING SEEMS TO BE
WORKING AT THE BORDER.
YOU’RE LOOKING AT LIVE DRONE
SHOTS WE’RE GETTING ALONG THE
BORDER HERE IN THE RIO GRANDE
AND THE AREA THAT SENATOR MIKE
BRAUN VISITED, INCLUDING THE
FACILITIES FOR MINORS MEANT TO
HOLD 250 PEOPLE AND PRESENTLY
HOUSES MORE THAN 4,000 LARGELY
TEENAGERS.
THE SENATOR IS BACK HOME IN
INDIANA RIGHT NOW.
HE JOINS US OUT OF JASPER.
SENATOR MIKE BRAUN, VERY GOOD
TO HAVE YOU.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN YESTERDAY,
SENATOR?
>> WELL, IT WAS A WHIRLWIND
TOUR.
WE GOT DOWN THERE A LITTLE
BEFORE MIDNIGHT, QUICKLY LOADED
UP, WENT DOWN TO THE RIO GRANDE
RIVER WHERE THERE’S A PORT OF
ENTRY AND THERE’S JUST A STREAM
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMING IN
WITH SIGNS AND ERRORS IN TERMS
TERMS--
ARROWS IN TERMS OF HOW TO DO
IT.
YOU CAN GET HALFWAY ACROSS THE
RIVER AND YOU’VE MADE IT,
THAT’S WHERE THE BOUNDARY IS.
OW BRAZEN THE OTHER SIDE IS,
THE SMUGGLERS AND COYOTES.
WE GET DOWN TO THE RIVER AND OF
COURSE NOTHING IS GOING ON
BECAUSE THEY KNEW WE WERE
COMING AND ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU
HEAR HECKLING FROM THE OTHER
SIDE AND I ASKED THE BORDER
PATROL, WHO IS THAT?
SPEAKING IN SPANISH.
HE SAID THOSE ARE COYOTES AND
SMUGGLERS SAYING REGARDLESS
WHAT YOU DO, WE’RE GOING TO
KEEP COMING.
THAT’S THE WAY THE TRIP
STARTED.
WE WENT BACK THAT EVENING.
YOU COULD SEE A STREAM OF
MOSTLY KIDS AND VERY YOUNG
ADULTS, SOME INFANTS, GOING
INTO TWO STAGING AREAS UNDER AN
INTERSTATE
INTERSTATE, UNDER A ROAD, PORT
OF ENTRY BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE COMING IN WITH THAT
WELCOME SIGN THAT BIDEN PUT OUT
THERE AND SHUT EVERYTHING DOWN
THAT TRUMP WAS DOING THAT WAS
WORKING BEFORE.
IT’S A MESS.
NEIL: NOW, AS YOU KNOW, THE
PRESIDENT AND THE WHITE HOUSE
HAVE POINTED TO THIS HAPPENING
MANY TIMES IN THE PAST THAT
THERE WAS A SPIKE IN THIS
ACTIVITY BACK IN 2019 AND THEY
BLAME AT THE TIME PRESIDENT
BIDEN CUTTING $450 BILLION IN
FUNDING TO MEXICO.
DO YOU BUY THAT?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE MAP, RON
JOHNSON DID IT, LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND WE’VE USED IT OFTEN RIGHT
HERE.
IT SHOWS ALL THE PEAKS AND
VALLEYS AND THE MOST RECENT ONE
WOULD HAVE BEEN WHEN TRUMP
STARTED TALKING ABOUT STAYING
IN PLACE IN MEXICO.
OF COURSE, THERE WAS A SURGE
BECAUSE WHAT IMPRESSED ME MOST
ARE THE PEOPLE ON THE OTHER
THERE ARE MAKING 4,000 BUCKS A
HEAD ON ANY CENTRAL AMERICAN
AND MEXICAN.
THAT’S PER PERSON, NOT FAMILY.
UP TO 20,000 ON OTHER
NATIONALITIES IF THEY CAN PAY
MORE AND THEY’VE GOT A
LOGISTICS SYSTEM, NEIL, THAT
KNOWS HOW TO WORK THE SYSTEM
WHEN YOU GIVE NEM THE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY.
IT WAS A 45-YEAR LOW WHICH
PRESIDENT BIDEN FAILED TO
MENTION WHEN YOU HAD THE WALL
BUILT AND EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVE
GAPS WHERE HE SHOULD IT DOWN
AND YOU HAVE PLACES IN MEXICO
WHERE YOU WEREN’T LET IN THE
COUNTRY AND WORKING WITH THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE COUNTRIES.
BIDEN POLITICALLY SAID WE’RE
STOPPING BECAUSE IT WAS TRUMP
AND HE’S GOT A FIASCO THAT 17
OTHER SENATORS WITNESSED AS
WELL.
NEIL: SENATOR, THERE ARE
ESTIMATES HERE THAT THE NUMBER
OF KIDS CROSSING THE BORDER
COULD KEEP SOARING.
ONE STUDY HAS IT AS MANY AS 18
TO 22,000 THE BORDER IN APRIL.
ANOTHER 25,000 IN MAY.
THERE’S NO WAY WE CAN KEEP UP
WITH THAT.
>> THERE’S NOT.
THE TOTAL FIGURE FEBRUARY WAS
ABOUT 100,000.
IT’S GOING TO HIT ABOUT 140,000
IN MARCH.
AND THIS IS ALONG THE WHOLE
SECTOR OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
TEXAS HAS GOT FOUR OR FIVE
SEPARATE SECTIONS THEMSELVES
AND QUARTER MILLION IS WHAT THE
BORDER PATROL SAYS THEY’RE
BRACING FOR.
YOU KNOW WHAT’S HAPPENING NOW?
YOU GET THERE, YOU’RE SO
OVERWHELMED YOU SAW THE
PICTURES IN THE FACILITIES.
THERE WAS A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION LADY THERE
TELLING US NOT TO TAKE
PICTURES.
BORDER PATROL TOLD US AS WELL,
BUT YOU COULD TELL THAT WAS
KIND OF PREFUNCTORY, AND THEY
KNEW WE WERE GOING TO.
THIS IS GOING TO GET ONLY WORSE
THAN BETTER.
WE TOOK A TRIP UP THE RIVER AND
BACK, SPANNED ABOUT A HALF
HOUR, 40 MINUTES.
AND I SAID HOW CAN PEOPLE GET
ACROSS AT THAT QUICKLY?
THEY SAID THEY’RE INGENIOUS, A
RAFT SYSTEM, GET HALFWAY ACROSS
THE RIVER NTHAT SPAN OF 30 OR
40 MINUTES WE’VE COME BACK,
THERE WAS A BODY FLOATING.
SO EVIDENTLY THEY TRIED TO GO
THROUGH AND SOMEONE DROWN IN
THE PROCESS, IN THAT 40 MINUTE